let's understand that of the deal I
think he wanted 20% all along but you
understood if you wanted up to 20% you
know that's not your opening bid right
right so he started at 15 and I I
guarantee you I guarantee you if he had
started at 20% like later and I had
factored we would have ended up at about
27 or 28 percent I've been a flat tax
guy for all my life you know I love the
idea you know let's just have a really
low rate everybody pays it you know you
make 10 times more money that I do I pay
you know you pay 10 times more tax and
not 50 times more attacks and get rid of
all the loopholes in the tax system so I
believe the free enterprise system is
the goose that lays the golden eggs all
right so I'm basically with you on all
of that but let's let's do the flat tax
for a second so I would be basically for
something like 15% for everybody would
you do something to help the people that
are at the lowest yes what's so a
certain amount of people were paying up
that sounds like an the standard flat
tax plan you said 15% I'd love that but
most plans were about 18% and then you
basically say for a family for roughly
your first say $30,000 he earned his tax
free and then you know above that amount
you pay a tax so you know people below
the poverty line are not paying any
federal income tax and I think most
people regard that as fair and equitable
and very pro-growth and we'd love to see
it the reason it doesn't happen is not
even because you know liberals oppose it
it's the special interest groups in
Washington do you think they want a flat
tax right now they did the lobbyists
make money buying and selling favors in
the tax code if you have a flat tax what
do they have to sell no more no more
favors if you really want to drain the
swap
go to a flat tax would you do anything
on the really high side of that so right
now is there something you would do just
to kind of even if it didn't work sort
of economically in your mind just to
kind of throw you know I progressed it's
a ball get it I get asked that question
a lot you know I don't like that because
I you know you say well why don't we
just have 20% for the really rich and
then they'll lose before not 25 why not
30 why not you know we have tax rates at
one point in this country 91% so I don't
like that idea because I think it
perverts the I love the idea everybody
plays pays the same
No you know the idea oh we're just gonna
have a surcharge on the Bill Gates and
the warren buffett's of the world they
will pay their tax you know when they
when they earn their money they will pay
it and by the way they're those are
people who employ you know some cases
hundreds of thousands of workers they
pay tax so I don't I want to I want to
retain the virtue and simplicity of one
rate system right those guys are also
always for raising taxes and yet they
don't voluntarily is that interesting
what do you make of that the month
there's someone called the patriotic
millionaires so something like a hundred
millionaires and billionaires have
signed something saying you know we want
to pay more tax I call them the
hypocritical millionaires because you
know the you know there's nothing to
prevent somebody you know at the bottom
line of your tax form is if you want to
pay more money into the Treasury you
know you can write a check and none of
them do that so my feeling is that they
are they want other people to pay more
tax but they don't want to pay more of
themselves and then then they say well
but the taxes isn't voluntary and I'm
like wait a minute
you know people voluntarily want to
serve you know people sign up for the
military though those are patriotic
people they care about our country and
they they're willing to give their you
know potentially their whole life for
our country but these quote patriotic
millionaires won't pay more tax
themselves but they want other people to
pay more tax doesn't become one of those
odd things where it's like the CEO of
Walmart or something will publicly say
that he's for $15 minimum wage where he
knows actually it won't ultimately hurt
him but it'll hurt the smaller
businesses that won't be able to afford
it he'll be able to afford it oh yeah
you know that's why a lot of the
regulations in Washington that you know
liberals want they are able to team up
with the big companies because the big
companies can absorb the cost of you
know requiring company to pay health
care benefits or education benefits or
raise their minimum wage so it's a way
of actually of strengthening the big
guys and strangling the small guys who
are trying to you know compete with the
with the big guys so you know the small
business are the ones who get hurt the
most by those kinds of regulations right
it's interesting that you mentioned in
relation to tax that you sort of you can
even if you threw somebody a bone that
it's never enough kind of which reminds
me of the $15 minimum wage thing where
Rasheeda Talib said well why not $20 and
then it's like well Bernie or Warren or
the rest of them
nothing to really stand on to say why it
should be 15 and not 20 because once you
artificial in other ways nobody I'm for
the highest wages Americans can possibly
get so how do you how do you ensure that
then without doing too much government
well you don't have to have the
government first of all one of the
principles you ask me about Prince of
economics one good principle is you
never want the government setting prices
or setting wages that's supposed to be
done by the free enterprise system those
law of supply and demand and when you
have the government come in and set you
know I'll give you as an aside you're
reliving here in Los Angeles you know in
a lot of cities you have rent control
you know to try to make you know housing
more affordable for poor people look we
want we all want people to have shelter
and a roof over their head but it turns
out you know this is a perfect example
of the law of unintended consequences it
turns out when you actually impose right
control you actually reduce the amount
of affordable housing you actually have
more people homeless not less the New
York City found that and yet liberals
seem to never you know understand that
message and it's the same thing you know
with what were you asking me about the
well the minute the minimum wage it's
not hinged to reality sort of so on
someone says it should be 15 well then
why not 20 I'm side are 24 so what
happens to happen when you raise the
minimum wage is you actually the people
who tend to get hurt the most are the
people with the least skilled because
you essentially priced them out of the
market and I always tell the story you
know I have two teenage sons I love them
to death but I'd never pay them fifty
five you know they don't have the
training and skills to to you know
warrant a $15 an hour wage why not you
know especially for young people let
them work for seven or eight dollars an
hour and gain the skills you know I
remember very well by the way my first
job I think most people listening was
watching the show remember that you
remember the first job you ever had
I do they check what was I was a
paperboy taken well care there's a
paperboy working in a small warehouse in
Northbrook Illinois and you know but you
learn a lot with your first job how to
show up on time how to be nice to your
class how to learn some skills so you
learn that you know whether you're
delivering newspapers or whether you're
you know working in a factory so I don't
like that about you know I like that
letting the wages rise and and that's
happened under trumped by the way we've
gotten a really nice wage gains under
through the free enterprise system and
creating a very like tight labor market
I mean workers have a lot of bargaining
power right now
so you advise Trump on the tax cuts a
couple years ago talk to me just a
little bit about like what's that like
when you're sitting in a room with this
guy like what what are his guiding
principles sort of economically what
you've kind of laid out there versus the
capitalists you have you do you know
Trump I've never met him first so he's
very he's a really good guy I mean
believe it or not I say half jokingly
you know that he's kind of most
politicians are wonderful people in
public and jerks in private Trump can be
a jerk in public but a wonderful but he
is a wonderful first probably I liked
him a lot he speak he's interesting he's
charming he's attentive to what you're
saying he looks at you straight in the
eye and he wants to know and he'll he'll
come at you if you say say you know I
like that he'll he'll joust with you if
he doesn't agree with your position
which you know he'll have four or five
people in the room and they'll argue and
that's what a good CEO should do not
just surround themselves with yes-man
but people who will argue out the point
so when you guys sat down and he's going
I want to cut taxes yeah this is one of
the things I promise now help me pull
this thing one example so it's a this
this tells you a lot about the tax bill
but it also tells you about Donald Trump
so I remember when we went into Trump
this was Larry Kudlow and our Larry's
now the chief economist and we said hey
you know we we showed him this chart
that had you know the US tax rate on our
businesses was 40 percent and the rest
of world was like on average about 20
percent and we said you know this is a
problem for us you know that is Larry
call that it's a 20% head start for all
the countries were competing with
because they've got a lower penalty that
they face and as a result of that
companies were leaving the United States
and they were going to Ireland or there
Greta Canada or they're going to Mexico
this was called inversions where
companies were giving up their American
citizenship to move somewhere else so
anyway we said to Trump we think you
should have a 20% rate in your tax plan
and I'll never forget he sat back and he
said no I'm not gonna do that we said
well why he said I want 15% and when
we're so interesting about that was that
from that moment until we passed the
bill in Tucson late December of 2017 he
always insisted on 15% always a meeting
with Mitch McConnell or Paul Ryan or any
public declaration 15-15-15 and I'll
never forget we're waiting for the final
though in the Senate because we needed
to get 50 votes in the Senate two passes
were nervous about whether we could do
this remember on Obamacare we came up
with 49 votes one vote short so we
didn't want to come up with 49 account
and so we're very nervous we're waiting
for McConnell to come back from his
come-to-jesus moment you know when they
had their final meeting and the post I
mean the Senate Republican clock to see
if they had 50 votes and I remember he
walks in I was right up to the president
he said you know mr. president I'm so
sorry I failed you I know you wanted
that 15% tax rate and I made up from an
argument I could possibly could and you
know I'm just I've failed you mr.
president what can I say you know I made
I couldn't convince my colleagues I said
I couldn't get you that 15% he said
would you take 20% and I really believe
this the the really interesting thing
about that story is I always thank God
thank you God that Donald Trump didn't
listen to Larry and I understand that of
the deal I think he wanted 20 percent
all along but you understood if you want
to end up at 20 percent you know that's
not your opening bid right right so he
started at 15 and I I guarantee you I
guarantee you if he had started at 20
percent like Larry and I had we would
have ended up at about 27 or 28 percent
it's because he started 15 the
negotiated position was 20 well we ended
up actually at 21 percent do you think
do you think basically that is his
secret sauce to everything I mean we
could even take this outside of the
world of economics just that that
negotiating like that is basically that
is his greatest skill well you know the
name of his book right the art video art
of the deal he's a good negotiator he is
you know I've seen him many times in
person and he knows how to negotiate you
know that's what's made him successful
in business and you know look he's made
mistakes as president I'm not an
apologist for Trump I like you know
where we are with the economy but yeah I
think this is one of his assets he's a
very good negotiator if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell